all right what is going on everybody and
welcome to yet another python and
robotics tutorial video in this video
we're going to be building on the last
one and this time we're going to allow
uh key input from a user into our robot
so we can actually control our robot
since we don't have any actual sensors
that will allow us to make a robot
autonomous at this time
so
what you're going to do at this point is
one of two things either you're going to
need to plug in a mouse a wireless
keyboard and an hdmi monitor to your
raspberry pi
or
you can remote desktop in if you do not
know how to remote desktop and i do have
a video
for that i will put a link to it in the
description so you can do that as well
anyway so let's go ahead and continue so
just as a reference to where we are
we're now
in here uh the only reason i really want
to bring this up actually is
if you don't have remote desktop you
would do sudo apt-get
install xrdp then you can use a remote
desktop that's like in built into your
windows
pc
so that aside i'm actually not going to
use that right now because i coding in
idle is somewhat easier
so we'll go into accessories file
manager
and then up here click on robotics
that's the directory we had and we've
been working on robot2
go ahead and just copy that and paste
that
i'm not sure if it's thinking
or maybe we not we didn't get a good
copy or something
it should work let's see cp
okay for whatever reason right clicking
wasn't working but control c control p
worked
and this time we'll call it robot three
dot pi rename
now we have robot three dot pi so right
click that uh for whatever reason open
with idle isn't here so i'm gonna use
open with
and programming and idle
okay
so wait a minute for that to open up let
me go ahead and edit um
edit this to be a little bit larger so
it's easier for everyone to see
20 bold
apply
all right there we go
and i'll just make it full screen
so uh now we've got uh
all of this code and now what we want to
do is we actually want to program
um
some sort of way for us to
enter input well the problem with python
is it runs as a script
and in order to give input the best
thing we really have is input or raw
input
natively anyways with python what you're
going to have to do is start
implementing some use of either c or
java
and luckily python actually works with c
very well naturally python is actually c
python
and so we can use a little bit of c um
and what we're going to have to do is
kind of a hacky way around it
or about going about doing this
and you could probably do it easier in
pure java or like javascript or
something like that but
we like python so we're going to do it
in python
so the first thing that we want to do is
we're going to use tkinter
and we also want um
trying to think if we want yeah i think
we'll take we might use system as well
so let's go ahead and do import sys for
system and then also we're going to
import capital t
kinter as tk
now we want to do is we actually want to
you know create this window so let's go
scroll down a little bit
we'll get rid of pivot right we don't
need that anymore let's make some more
space
and now we want to have is some way for
us to register a keys
input so we're going to define key
underscore input
and
the parameter will be event
and then we're going to
we're going to run initiate
initiate here
instead of
uh
in each of these so go ahead and delete
all of your initiate initiates here here
here
and
here
and here well we have more of these
functions than i thought we had
in here okay so make sure you get rid of
all your init uh empty parms because
we're now gonna put in key input and
then what we're gonna end up doing is
depending on the key input
we'll do something that might be go
forward go reverse whatever but each
time it's gonna be something else
uh so anyway so that's what we've got
going on there now what we're going to
do is let's go ahead and print
whatever key we used
um
event dot
character
and then now key underscore
press equals event dot character
and then sleep underscore time is going
to equal
something let's do 0.030
and now we actually want to start
programming what our keys are going to
be so the arrow keys are actually not
too easy i'm not sure what the special
name for an arrow key is so what we're
going to end up using is the wasd
q and e
so w will be forward s will be reverse a
will be turned left d will be turned
right
q will be pivot left or counter
clockwise and e right or clockwise
so
we're going to use if key underscore
press dot lower just in case the user
accidentally leaves their caps lock on
equals w
then we're going to do forward
uh sleep
time
so we can edit sleep time later and we
don't have to like edit all of the
versions of it
so if that's the case we're going to
move forward
l if key press dot lower equals
s
well what did we say s was well that's
obviously reverse
reverse
sleep time
l if key press dot lower
equals
a
that's a will be a turn
left
for sleep
time
l if key press dot lower
equals d
that will be a turn
right
for
sleep time
and then
uh we've done the wasd so now we want to
do the q and e so l if key press dot
lower equals q
then we're going to use
pivot
left
for sleep time we should have called
sleep time like st
and then lf key
press
dot
lower equals
e
pivot underscore right
for
the
sleep time
okay that should be everything for key
input
now the next thing that we want to do is
scroll down a little bit and actually i
guess we have enough space really for
what we're going to put in so i'll leave
key input there for anybody who wants to
pause
now
we're going to say
we'll call this
i
guess i don't know command
equals t k dot capital t underscore k so
command equals t k dot key t k
then com oops
command dot
bind
and here what we want to bind this is
you have to type this exactly key
press
we want to bind the key press
as key
or key press key input
now
we want to run command dot main loop
and that should be it so now what we're
going to get here
is
when we run this we're going to get a
little window that pops up
and as long as we're in that window
whatever key we press it's going to log
that key and it's going to log that key
for 0.030 seconds if anybody can give me
a way to know how to
like log like when it's as long as the
key is down uh that would be great
and to like wait that long i'm not
really sure how how to get that to set
up so
this just seems like an easy quick way
to show you guys so that's why i've gone
with it so anyway we'll save that and i
guess we could just run it via idle even
though the problem with idle is idle so
slow
so actually i don't really want to run
it through idle because once you start
pasting a bunch of stuff it'll slow down
so actually this is roblox 3.5 so exit
out of this
and we saved our idle here so let's just
bring this up
and let's cd into robotics
make sure it's there so there's a robot
three dot pi so now we can do sudo
python robot three dot pi hit enter
and
oh i guess we did bind instead of blind
let's let's go back and look at uh
what we've done
i think we just typoed
when we did command.bind i probably
typed blind
and i was too blind to miss it or see it
let's go back down to the
bottom yeah sure enough
command.blowing
okay
so fix that save that hopefully no one
else typed blind
uh
anyway coming back over here let's try
that one more
time and here's our little window so as
we press something like i'll press p
oh it's very unhappy with p
anyway
oh see we've got a lot of lag going on
in our in my window here i think i'd
rather use um
well maybe if i put this down let's see
let's minimize this maybe maybe that'll
there we go that helped a little bit it
was
having problems uh relaying the data
back to that screen anyway so minimize
it and just be in this window so i press
w
and sure enough it goes forward and i'm
like kind of tapping it and stuff so you
can like tap it or you can hold it and
it'll go
and then you can turn
turn
pivot
pivot
backwards forwards
now i wonder though
uh we do have a small problem if you hit
any other key it just does
weird things
i think it just maybe runs what the last
thing was i'm not sure
maybe what we need to do though is go to
the bottom
and where we have
lfl if elif
else
let's just run a pass
let's see if that'll work for us
so first let's close out of this tk
window and i guess we'll leave this up
just in case we need to do any more
editing
let's bring this back up
and we'll run this again and in fact let
me let me if i make this window smaller
because i'd just like to show you is at
least streaming the
come on window
okay good enough all right
so we run it here's our window
w is forward
still a little laggy but not so bad just
works better if you're not
see at least this is like kind of
streaming it like every you know point
zero three seconds anyway i'm gonna
minimize it now let's hit another key
yeah for some reason whenever we hit
another another key
it goes crazy
but as long as you hit a key that it is
expecting
doesn't do anything
maybe if i hit another key we could just
run clean up or something
trying to think of how
not really sure what's going on there
i'll have to look at it later feel free
to leave a comment if you want uh on
what you think is happening or why it's
running random stuff whatever
it goes in reverse
now go forward
yeah it seems i want to do like whatever
the last whatever the last thing was so
maybe we should run like a cleanup or
something
i bet that would do it
anyway
uh that's going to conclude the video
we've got our commands now so you should
be able to control your car you know do
whatever you want turn it and all this
and what i'm going to go ahead and do is
i'll put the top on the car and the next
video uh we'll go ahead and run the car
somewhere the motors are weak so as you
can see i've got carpet in this room but
i do have like some laminate floor in my
kitchen and i'll run it in there and we
can see how how this robot actually does
so hopefully you guys are enjoying if
you do have any questions or comments
feel free to leave those below as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions and until the
next video